i've been questioned
about
my non-for-profit doing what we do right
here on o block in chicago and we should
be able to you know maybe question what
others are doing as well
and
the one question that stands out in my
mind that i woke up thinking about
is what has black lives matter
done for our community
[Music]
what's up everybody what's up listen i
am pastor corey brooks
from the south side of chicago right
here on o block old named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed
we decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to call it opportunity block
that's the reason why i'm staying in
this tent for 100 days from november
20th to february 28th
talking about the issues that so concern
us right here in chicago
and america talking about the violence
that we experience every single day but
also trying to inform everyone that on
the south side of chicago
project hood we're building a center the
game all of that it's going to be a game
changer i want to shout out fox for
giving me a platform every day to bring
to you
rooftop revelations today i have with me
two brothers who i admire so greatly and
we're going to jump right in uh um they
can tell you their names and my fact
brilliant tell who you are real quick do
we sign in washington uh ceo of the
institute for black solidarity with
israel
darwin giles former ethnic vice chair of
the michigan republican party
two of these brothers listen i'ma jump
right in because what i want to talk
about is so hot
ah
yes
so there are a lot of people who see all
of this money
given
specifically
to black lives matter
and i know if i've been questioned
about
my not-for-profit doing what we do right
here on o block in chicago
then we should be able to you know maybe
question what others are doing as well
and
the one question that stands out in my
mind that i woke up thinking about
is what has black lives matter
done for our community from your
perspective well
uh let's see
if i clock it from when they begin 2013
to now uh
you can use the issue of bringing some
awareness to some of these very high
profile situations like in ferguson that
type of thing
but as a whole
my answer that question is not very much
not only that
has been some detriment where the black
community is concerned there's lots of
different reasons a couple of them you
touched on one that's the books
money
some 50 million dollars ferguson back in
2014 some 90 million dollars in 2020 but
as you said how did that impact how does
that positively
impact the black community on the ground
like oh block for example right and then
also i would say again as a brother who
represents a black israel zionist
organization the demonization of israel
not only is it has nothing to do with
what's going on in like a ferguson or
chicago or oakland or anything like that
it actually is exploiting the pain and
the situations that are going so in
other words i'm not fixing trying to
help oh block let me use oh block okay
for this prop over here that's i mean
beyond
i mean that's that's heinous that's
right you you're using you're propping
off with the pain or other people
smiling to that question not very much
happy now for the black community yes
let me you answer that very well let me
let me ask you another question exactly
um
do you feel like black lives matter
has
used the black community
[Music]
and given us nothing in return from from
your perspective i don't want to put
words in your mouth i don't know how i
feel about it correct but but do you
think they've used the black community i
would like to say that i believe those
there are individuals who are very um
honest in their intentions uh who are
apart because yes they want to stand in
solidarity with the black community but
if you know just as my brother's keeper
we're all blocked this is technically
obama former president obama's you know
hometown uh a slogan is good but where's
the results that's all i ask what is the
results okay what have you really
impacted what what actually uh crisis
issues have you helped solve
uh and to me those are just honest
questions so when it comes down to it i
believe that far as the establishment
needs to be held accountable and imma
say this
because they
said and talked a good game
but where's the results and i think for
black people we demand not only justice
but accountability for people who have
used our struggle and our pain to profit
and gain and politicize but they're not
helping
criminal justice reform they're not
helping attack the issues of mass
incarceration the literary issues the
illiteracy issues in california
we need real justice for us and
accountability
you know what i heard a statement um
that i want to just ride for just a
second
um
shelby steele who was real respected
um who also has
written and talked about many issues
that we talk about today
he said that
black lives matters
sells
a
brand a brand of
innocence
and they sell their brand of innocence
to whites
and i thought about wow if they're
selling a brand of innocence to whites
then what am i selling what is project
good selling
and i thought about that
and i thought well we sell hard work
we sell
that the individual has to take
responsibility and accountability for
that life we sell that racism is not the
biggest problem that we face we sell
that capitalism is extremely important
for us getting out of poverty correct
that's what we sell
which route
which brand
do you think is more effective
for what we're doing and meeting
in our community today
well
clearly it's the one that you're just
underscored at the end pastor
that
entrepreneurial one right that
industrial one but not only is that the
case now that has always been the case
right when you talk about post slavery
america
and the people like the giants like
booker t washington right who preached
the exact same thing right we talked
about some of those quotes over 100
years ago and he's talking about the
independence the building of businesses
again as we talked about before the
whole issue of the concept of black wall
street he's the one who coined the term
negro wall street right and that not
just the mindset but the actual these
businesses and everything that came
about
so i believe that it's very it's been
very clear history has taught us that
more so than political power political
power is fine to have but what we found
is what's even more powerful is that
capital is an economic power right
because economic power can dictate
political power right but you could have
political power and have no economic
power and you get vacuums and situations
like we see all over the country right
where we have things like
politics but what's happening on the
ground other than these positions that
are being held what's happening in our
school what's happening with our
businesses and that type of thing so i
believe that that
second part is the most important that's
the books that hard work what project
code is that's the part that's the most
important absolutely absolute group so
i'm gonna give you a real live example
one of my supporters actually just
mentioned this to me concerning student
loan debt okay now there's some proposal
to eliminate a certain amount of school
loan debt and i understand and i support
that
but what is better you having the
economics a high wage and you having a
well good paying job or you be able to
have enough money to not only pay off
your own debt but start a business and
invest and you own and take take full
authority in control over your destiny
and your own fortitude or just basically
let the government give you something
that's going to cancel your debt but
never actually put you in a position to
give you free market enterprise
solutions i believe in capitalism with
ethics and has been proven globally that
capitalism increases uh your wealth
capacity and so it helps you eliminate
poverty so i believe in having a strong
economy being able to have high wages to
pay off your debts you got enough money
you can pay off your own student loans i
know people who do it
okay so without that we have a serious
problem yes you know
listen
the truth of the matter is this
from where i'm standing
there's a brand
[Music]
that tries to make white people feel
guilty
try to make them
feel
as if they need to support something so
that they don't feel like they are
racist
i'ma tell you right off the bat
that's not my brain
i'm not trying to get white people to
support
what we do
or conservatives to support what we do
because i think all white people are
guilty and i think all white people are
racist and i think every system in
america is racist i do not believe that
i do not buy that
i have a brand that says this
i believe capitalism works
i believe individual responsibility
works
i believe the dignity for having work
works i believe that government
will never solve our problems and come
in and save us i believe that
and i'm asking people
hey just support this brand
support me being on this route for 100
days
trying to bring attention and awareness
to body support me
building this community center so that
we can take responsibility to help these
young people
transform their lives and transform this
community
that's the brand i'm selling
well that's just my rooftop revelations
until tomorrow
peace
you